let me play this uh Trump truth Donald
Trump posted this today at 307
effectively accusing Alvin Bragg of I I
guess abusing a woman we'll put it that
way let's play the ad for George Soros
funded Democrat Alvin Bragg is known as
the worst da in the country his soft on
crime policies have Unleashed violent
criminals on innocent citizens and
turned New York City into a hellscape of
crime drugs and Chaos however Alvin
Bragg's crimes against the people of New
York may just be the tip of the iceberg
before Bragg's election it was revealed
that Soros cut off five hundred thousand
dollars in funds to Bragg's campaign
it was reported that there were
disturbing allegations leveled against
Sprague by an unnamed woman there was no
investigation into the victim's charges
by the Manhattan DA's office and Alvin
Bragg is yet to be charged I'm the only
thing standing between the American
dream and total Anarchy
Madness and chaos and that's what it is
I'm representing you I'm just here
always remember
they're coming after me because I am
fighting for you that's what's happening
so he's already using this to campaign
right but um I hate to do it but he's
making me defend Alvin Bragg all right
here here's the issue right Alvin Bragg
was not a was not formally Accused by
anybody who we know an unnamed woman is
the story and
there were no charges what does that say
it says he didn't do anything that's it
if some like unnamed Anonymous woman
accused him of doing something and there
were no charges am I going to be a lie
oh man you know I gotta go for that I
got that Donald Trump's a bad guy no I'm
not playing that game I don't like brag
I don't like Soros funded Diaz I think
they're awful I think this guy's
destroying New York City
well I think they have enough ammunition
against him to not even bring that up I
think it I think just takes away from
how bad he is as a D.A and by the way
probably the worst da in the country is
Phillies I forgot his uh I forgot the
name of the Philly person but I mean
Philadelphia Is A Wasteland A Wasteland
right yeah those videos but but I think
that they had they have more than enough
ammunition on Bragg to just completely
ignore all those distractions right
there I think that takes away from how
bad of a job he's already doing as
district attorney is this Larry krasner
Philadelphia yeah that's a that's
another sword that's like a top Soros
one I believe okay Soros is a vampire
yeah I think I think a good analogy for
that guy he's an evil evil oh guys
he's the definition of evil I mean he's
like you know evil as they come he
thinks he's good that's what's weird
yeah sure yeah I don't think he thinks
he's good
no there there are a lot of people that
I think they they think they're good and
there are a lot of people that will play
the philosophical game of like there's
such thing as good or evil there's the
action blah blah I don't care
like I get it everybody thinks it's a
hero of their own story but
uh George Soros is just an evil guy well
he spends tens of millions of dollars
electing district attorneys in in the
most liberal District Attorneys uh in
the United States that are letting
criminals back on the streets liberal is
the incorrect word leftist yeah sorry
you're right you're right about that I'm
not liberal at all but I don't think I
don't think leftist is either he's
funding
he's funding Joker acolytes he's he's
funding uh someone actually uh commented
in early in one of my earlier segments I
said what these DA's are doing is like
the Joker releasing all the bad guys
from Arkham Asylum someone mentioned
Bane did that uh Bane in Batman releases
all of the criminals into the city I
think that was uh the movie though
pretty sure it's the Joker that breaks
everybody out of Arkham Asylum in the
comics either way comic book villainy
these D these these these Soros Diaz are
comic book villains who are unleashing
crime into all of these cities it's like
Lex Luthor level stuff
who was in charge of releasing all the
prisoners from prisons uh when kovid
started with lockdowns when they were
telling us for breaking lockdown they
were literally all doing what they're
doing in California too yeah that's when
I started feeling like America had
turned into Arkham when everyone's just
getting told they can leave the prisons
but then if you don't mask up or do
whatever they will arrest you and put
you in jail they want you to wear a mask
in a store now the salon I don't know
the salon owner in Texas who got
arrested and I think Abbott it was
Abbott or someone pointed out you're
arresting this woman because she opened
her Salon while releasing violent
criminals because of coveted policies
what is going on the lady who was
selling stuff on Facebook live and it
came to restore well the most shocking
thing too is a lot of people aren't
capable of like processing the whole job
of a district attorney so it's kind of
this like in invisible Enemy Within
cities what happens is they let all
these bad guys out these these violent
criminals back on the street they commit
crimes crime crime rates Skyrocket and
then it gives Democrats another
Boogeyman that's not the district
attorney they focus on guns and taking
away more gun rights they leverage those
high crime statistics to strip more of
your rights away instead of focusing on
the just garbage district attorneys in
these in these uh cities I was regarding
this video that Trump put out we just
listened to I it I don't like that he's
going at he's the city does the
personality like oh I got attacked I'm
gonna attack the guy that attacked me I
want to I want to do personal attacks
and also he sounded tired man I just
listened to this Biden video of him uh
vetoing the Senate you know the the
Congressional bill that they're trying
to pass and Biden sounds like this when
he's talking like he's so old withered
and tired and now Trump sounds just
tired these guys we need new blood this
is just yeah is so silly Trump hasn't
yet in a while is he 76 right now Trump
I think so yes yes I agree but I think
you know Trump's got to finish that
character Arc he's got to finish what
he's what he came here to do 76. he's
the front runner for a reason he's the
story is not over yet we are on you know
that we're nearing the final chapters
but we are still not at the end of the
book
I hope so because I I voted from the
last for 2020 but the pardoning thing
was one of the things that really
bothered me well the way the way he went
out with the pardoning you know who we
partying
that was a
right he could have got those guys out
of prison right and and I'm not talking
like if someone committed to violent
crime charge arrest them that's fine
yeah but some of these people were
sitting in for you know six months or
even years some people are still there
passing right and misdemeanors I I have
actually a a guy that I know um he went
in there uh just reporter he's been
casual reporter
basically a registered Democrat I think
his whole life not even not a hardcore
political guy either just kind of
standard you know California guy
Democrat and uh he went in there with a
DSLR camera around his neck non-violent
crime going to prison for four years
wait what going to prison for four years
not he his problem was is he was an
independent journalist and uh photo like
Photo journalist and um I don't believe
he had like a totally legit press pass
but yeah I mean you're trying to at
worst you're talking what is that a
trespassing charge but what they do with
these people they're making an example
out of them and they're in their pinning
them with obstruction of an official
proceeding and getting them with these
insane charges that like if you look at
this guy for one second you're like he's
not obstructing anything literally went
in there with a camera to go document
what was happening on January 6th yeah
well they went to prison for there was
that uh that John Sullivan guy whatever
his name was exactly I was thinking he
he was in there filming and documenting
and they got him as well and he was
instigating on some of those videos he
was saying yeah did he break a window or
something he was instigating in a lot of
in a lot of those videos and he sold
that footage to a lot of a lot of
corporate media places CNN and was on
those places as like a talking head you
know and then it came out that he may be
a bad actor you know no one knows they
said he was antifa maybe well then all
these different things yeah he wasn't
radical yeah it was I believe he was but
they will say he wasn't can you do a
thing where if you're gonna pardon
because I think there's a lot of
confusion of who did what so rather than
be like I'm gonna pardon these 40 of
these people because you still don't
know who did what can you say I'm gonna
pardon every instance of this crime
between the hours of 1pm and 9 p.m in
this place and then later when we find
out who was involved in that particular
I'm going to Pardon all the trespassing
violations so then later as it comes out
like who did what every time a
trespassing violation comes out it gets
tossed is that a potential way to Pardon
crimes
I have no idea all all that matters is
they're making example out of these
Trump had a couple weeks left and he
could have been like nope you're get him
out
what a drop of the ball for leadership I
agree with you I I would say I I look at
these j6ers the same way I look at Alex
Jones and a few of the others when it
came to testing the waters with
censorship in America you know I really
look at these j6ers as testing the
waters when it came to uh political
persecution in the United States and
look what they're doing now yeah look at
look how far they're about to go like
actually uh going after Donald Trump and
for some BS you know you made a good
point earlier before we were recording
about how this is like the image of this
will be so explosive just the purple oh
they're literally doing it just for that
and it'll be for both sides that image
yeah they're going to use it on on the
left is like look at this we've
destroyed this monster this Boogeyman
we've created on corporate media and
then the Trump side will be like we're
gonna put it on shirts and sell it yeah
Nelson Mandela basically I don't see a
way that it doesn't backfire I I see
this as being I mean you know you don't
want to be like indicted that's awful
but but I see it's been amazing for
Trump's campaign and Trump honestly it's
going to be like that Meme of Kyle
Rittenhouse and Greta tunberg where it
says compare you know our 17 year old
with their 17 year old tells you
everything you need to know and the left
and the right share them even in the
exact same ways to the left they're like
wow great at tunberg ooh Kyle on the
right's like ooh Greta wow Kyle but it's
the same image it exemplifies what Scott
Adams was saying about the same screen
with two different movies on at the same
it's nuts yes so we're going to see a
photo of trump being arrested and the
left is going to share and be like oh
this proves it and the right's gonna
share it like oh this proves it I guess
it sounds like an nft waiting to be made
right and I guess to clarify what I just
said uh fantastic for Trump when it
comes to raising money to getting his
base you know uh re-energized awful for
the country yeah awful yes because if
you're a Democrat amazing for Law and
Order and for our democracy and if
you're a trump supporter Republican it's
amazing for his campaign and chance for
re-election and then all it's doing is
pushing everybody into hyper
tribalization man when I was like 10 I I
learned about Nelson Mandela was like in
the late 80s and he was in jail or just
got let out of jail and I asked my dad
like why was he in jail he was a
political prisoner and I was like what
what does that mean what did he do wrong
and he's like no no it just means that
the government didn't like him and I was
like 10 or 11 when I learned that they
could do that I was like what they can
just put you in jail if they don't like
well imagine being born in any other
part of the world or at any other time
I don't like that guy and they cut your
head off on the street and be like he
talked crap about the governor you're
not allowed to do that like we're lucky
that we can protect us we're so lucky I
don't think we get it for very long to
be honest with you I think I think you
know we're we're slipping when it comes
to that polite society that moral
society that holds on to that you know
amazing life that we've grown up with I
think that we're slipping away from that
for sure thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time